never fear truth and why isn't ricky
very circumcised
of peace now i don't have to go into who
johnny depp
is i have a feeling you will see each
other again
ridiculous humiliating ludicrous painful
savage
on
unimaginable
brutal
cruel
awful one of the most famous hollywood a
star actors in the world like 50 makes
me insane not a fruit no i'm all men i
even fought in wwe too what i'm saying
to you
is you should give it to somebody that
don't know any better because that's it
for gazing all right
that's it for me
and his life was just put on display as
a circus for the whole world to see i
could tell you that as soon people were
watching on their phones as soon as this
verdict was read there were some cheers
outside of the courtroom and i've always
believed in johnny i believe that men
can be victims and
us having family members that have been
victims of domestic violence
i have to i stand with johnny and many
of you who idolize these hollywood
actors inspired to be like them you
thinking that this is what life is all
about that people are happy if they get
fame and fortune you really got to see
that it's not really what it's painted
out to be you found that drugs are the
only way to numb your pain
right
they've always been
a medicine from a yes a numbing agent
johnny depp being one of the most famous
hollywood actors who had all the money
all the fame
all the material things all the women
this morning when i i got to work there
was a line of women and i said what are
these people all doing here they
certainly weren't here for me but they
were there waiting for you to come
tonight but he's still numbing up all
that pain that he has inside he's got a
void obviously and he's numbing it with
alcohol and drugs and you said yesterday
that in fact i i think you said you take
drugs to numb the demons right
i don't know that i said to numb the
demons but i
have well
if i did say demons and and you would
sometimes drink whiskey in the mornings
too right
during this time period um
i i
i you know i mean
isn't happy hour any time
and
that cocaine that those white lines
those are coca that's cocaine right
i would assume yeah and that's that's
your cocaine that you kept in that box
that says property of jd with the skull
and crossbones isn't it well the
beautiful composition of the photograph
would suggest that certainly he also
thought he settled down maybe he thought
that was the purpose that bring him
peace and happiness so he got himself
what he thought was the most beautiful
woman which ended up causing him the
most pain it was a mess i was a wreck i
was
shaking and
i just didn't understand why
um and then i
looked down and
realized that the
the
the tip of my finger
had been
severed
and
i was
looking directly at
my
bones his cigarette
and and um
this is after the finger had
gone away
um
and she stubbed it out in my in in my
face and um on my cheek didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
babe you're not punched don't tell me
what it feels like to be punched you
know even a lot of fights been around a
long time i don't know
you didn't get punched you got hit i'm
sorry i hit you like this but i did not
punch you i did not deck you i was
hitting you i don't know what the
promotion of my actual hand was but
you're fine i did not hurt you i did not
punch you i was hitting you johnny
physical fights
i did start a physical fight you did so
yes you did so you did the right thing
the big thing the you know what you are
admirable now when i ask you a question
some of you guys brought this to my
attention and from our research it seems
to be true but i want you to look it up
to go ahead and verify for yourself
captain jack sparrow was a muslim
who'd have thought so the question is
did johnny depp play the role of a
muslim convert some of you already like
hell no no he didn't well check it out
check it out for yourself i'll share
with you a couple of things that we
found jack sparrow you know the famous
movie i haven't seen it myself but jack
sparrow aka
john ward we came across many articles
one of them in the daily sabbah that
reads jack sparrow might be inspired by
a muslim captain born in england in the
mid 1550s captain jack ward namely jack
sparrow was a legendary pirate who was
believed to have sailed to tunisia where
he converted to islam
with his crew and served in the ottoman
navy it goes on to say jack sparrow
whose real name is jack ward was a
famous sailor and pirate who was born in
england and sailed across the
mediterranean sea he converted to islam
and served in the ottoman empire in the
last years of his life it goes on to say
that captain jack was a heavy drinker
but he quit alcohol after his conversion
while the historical character of
captain jack sparrow in the movie was an
englishman historical facts indicate
that he led an adventurous life and he
converted to islam submission to the
creator not the creation it's also noted
here we have in wikipedia where it says
jack ward or birdie also known as yusuf
was an english ottoman pirate who later
converted to islam and became john ward
or birdie also known jack ward or later
as yusuf the bbc history magazine also
revealed john ward as the pirate behind
the character i thought it's very
interesting if this is true which it
seems it is
that johnny depp played the role of a
muslim convert and again a muslim is
simply one who submits his or her will
to the creator of the heavens and earth
the same way jesus moses abraham last
final master prophet muhammad did
captain object now what's johnny depp's
experience with religion or god you had
uncle was a preacher right i had an
uncle who was a preacher
my mom my mom my dad never really had
anything that you could
call religion interestingly enough it
goes back to his childhood and what he
observed going on around him at the time
it's you know maybe i'm six seven years
old and suddenly you see
grown-ups adults you know
throwing their hands up into the air
screaming i'm saved
running up and grabbing his ankle and
kissing his shoe and speaking in tongues
and all that stuff we know that johnny
depp will go to the church to listen to
his uncle danny preach
but i had an uncle who was a preacher
my uncle denny
and
you know they
we'd have to go watch him preach on
sunday and uh we can conclude that
whatever he was exposed to in the church
the concept of god the trinity
god dying from people's sins the
crucifixion these are the kind of things
the basic things that people are exposed
to in the church probably didn't lay
well with him and he obviously rejected
it
so at that
ripe old age of six or seven years old i
realized
this is [ __ ]
johnny depp seems like a deep thinker
and he talks about the gift of being
alive
being alive
he also gives advice about searching for
simplicity
first thing i would say is
search for simplicity
so if you're giving that advice
hopefully you'll take the advice
yourself johnny because there is nothing
more simple there's nothing more lucidly
clear than the pure monotheism
the simple message of islam the simple
message of the purpose of life that we
find in the quran so invite you johnny
depp the fans of johnny depp even amber
heard all of you guys to go ahead and
take a sincere look into islam without
the prejudices the preconceived notions
with an open heart and an open mind and
since you already played the part of a
muslim convert captain jack sparrow was
a muslim
who'd have thought it's true the
character of captain jack sparrow so
famously played by johnny depp in the
pirates of the caribbean movies is based
on a real person and that person was a
muslim convert
how cool is that john ward aka jack
sparrow look at what was so powerful of
islam that had him accept islam and give
up alcohol and changed his life for the
better which brought him peace and
contentment and happiness where not only
him but his whole crew accepted islam
and even his wife once you like to
get married again and find a wife that
you can actually trust and you can live
in peace with but look at john ward who
ended up getting married to his wife
and they both accepted islam you
obviously want peace and contentment
johnny depp you obviously have not found
that even up until now and i'm going to
tell you the truth you're not going to
find it in the way you're going trapped
in your own mind and your own desires in
your own personal philosophy in a buffet
of other people's opinions and
philosophies it's like fumbling in the
dark looking for a key or lost in the
ocean without a sail or a rudder can you
imagine but what's worse being in this
life without guidance without purpose
and that's where islam comes in to give
you purpose to help you understand why
you've been created and to give you hope
to give you peace to give you
contentment not only in this life but
paradise in the next now this video has
a good chance of getting our friend
johnny depp
and obviously the fans of johnny depp
with your help inshallah god willing
because as we know johnny depp is a
youtube fiend hey as i said i'm a
youtube theme so let me leave you with
this johnny depp as you've said
that life is about celebrating and being
grateful if we could celebrate
every breath
that we take
because nothing's a guarantee
if we could celebrate the breath
and the exhale
which is
being alive
so consider this as potential words
coming from your creator and inshallah
god willing you can if you put it to the
test confirm like we have that they are
actually coming from the crate of the
heavens and earth based on proof and
evidence all you'd have to do is invest
a little bit of time with some sincerity
sprinkled on it and you'd come to the
same conclusion so consider this as
potential words coming from your creator
let me let you hear this and then i'll
translate it quran you've read so many
books
you've identified so many fake man-made
religions that are out there you're
your innate nature rejected god being a
man being a human being and you know the
all the other man-made religions out
there and i'm quite sure that you have
never sincerely looked into islam
or read the quran look at what allah god
almighty is saying how can you reject
faith in allah
in your creator
seeing that you were without life
and then he gave you life and then he
will cause you to die
and will again bring you to life and
again to him you shall return so if you
talk about being grateful how dare can
we be ungrateful to our creator who gave
us the ability to inhale and exhale as
you talk about if we could celebrate
every breath
that we take so just imagine that you
didn't exist you were nothing we were
nothing just 70 years ago you're in your
60s now just about 70 years ago you
didn't exist there was no johnny johnny
who then after that just imagine you
were this in layman's terms uh sticky
slime
sperm so god almighty is saying that he
gave you life and then he's going to
cause you to die and then he'll bring
you back to life and every second we're
getting closer and closer to our final
destination towards our departure date
johnny depp and you've lived this life
you've been all the coke and the dope
and the drugs still numbing the pain you
found that drugs are the only way to
numb your pain
right
they've always been um a medicine from
yes a numbing agent
so let's conclude here with you tried
everything else
why not give islam a try look into
the muslim converts life that captain
jack sparrow was a muslim
who'd have thought that you played the
role that you played
in this film and why not after you
looked into the crown if you're sincere
you will conclude that this is the truth
i want to live life according to god's
will not my desires and when i talk
about god i'm not talking about a man in
the heavens with a beard that resembles
a human being or jesus is a god or a
trinity i'm talking about the one who
created this whole universe and
everything in it the one and only the
one that you cannot imagine and fathom
he's not like you or me he doesn't have
an area called zip code a color a skin
tone a nationality he's one and alone
worthy of worship and he sent prophets
and messengers
they all came with the same message
worship one and only one god and be
morally upright and when you talk about
simplicity
search for simplicity
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and prepare yourself for a day of
judgment where at the end it'll be a
hellfire or a paradise and it's not
taking a risk that at the end
after all this drama it was a mess i was
a wreck i was
shaking and
i just didn't understand why all the
problems with life that we cannot escape
oh my car won't start oh geez you know
the cat dropped dead
and even after this wind that you just
got you'll be excited for a little bit
and with all the fans that even still
love you love you jordy
johnny johnny johnny i love you bro i
love you bro i love you bro i love you
you'll be alone in that grave and pretty
soon after some times all the hit films
that you made
it'll be forgotten so what else do you
have to lose
and i'll give you an idea
after you take some sincere time you
look into islam
you can come back make a hit film
on the real history of how jack sparrow
aka john ward would change his name to
yusuf i'll even leave you with some
homework why not read the story of yusuf
who john ward changed his name to read
the story of yusuf in the quran and just
how beautiful this prophet was and look
at the tests and trials that he went
through and by the way it was connected
to a woman and all you got to do to
start with is be sincere and ask ask for
the guidance
say the one who created me the one who
created this whole universe and
everything in it guide me guide me guide
me
and then put your thinking cap on
open your heart and mind and look into
this way of life this way of life that
was sent to all these messengers and
prophets they brought the same message
they didn't brought bring conflicting
messages
worship the one creator the one who
created you the one who created jesus
moses abraham the last and final
messenger who was sent for you me and
all of us living today prophet muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him
and we'll see you next time simplicity
it is worship the creator not the
creation thank you for tuning in stay
tuned in a second where i'm gonna get
you guys a free gift for you and johnny
johnny if you'd like to learn more reach
out have your team reach out to my team
and would love to connect and we'll love
to help you along your way
on the next journey in life the best
journey in life and i can guarantee you
if you're sincere it will be inshallah
until next time peace be with you
assalamu alaikum i cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you're not yet
muslim and you're tuning in to see what
these muslims are talking about and
you'd like a free copy of the quran go
and visit the deenshow.com we'll take
care of the postage and everything and
get it delivered to you and if you still
have some questions
about islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum and if you like this episode of
the dean show like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum